with the post-modernists and the
post-structuralists have done post 1960s
is they basically say if it's not
Material if you can't see it and cause
an effect it's not real
and that's that's a that's a tragedy to
believe and so yes the the byproduct of
that is so you have two things happening
at once America pulls back from its
values that wants to find can you go to
the uh it's very powerful but then the
they kind of buried the lead in fact
they didn't incorporate it which I just
want to reiterate it is a fact that we
are the most depressed most suicidal
most anxious most medicated most alcohol
addicted in history now you might say
well Charlie that's causation and
correlation hard to say that they aren't
connected hard to say that if patriotism
religion Community involvement having
kids collapses and all the negative
indicators Skyrocket that there isn't
some sort of relationship there